Shariff its Ross Tucker really
appreciate your time and it's just
amazing to me to look at you play in 13
years and to think that Kobe played
seven more years how impressed are you
just with the fact that he was able to
play NBA basketball for 20 seasons um I
don't know impressive the right word I'm
probably jealous see you in hospital
play just just awesome awesome awesome I
mean you gotta add enhancements no say
five thirteen years old regular 13 or 14
year career and you know all the playoff
runs deep playoff finals and that sort
of thing that that he also you know
we're enter on the body that he had and
to be able to you know relatively until
you know the last few years you know
injury free and that's what I saw for
not miss her a ton of game but
consistent consistency and it's
consistency to play at a really really
high level and then they go out you know
just in an amazing way you know you
probably couldn't you know generic just
awesome know I sat and watched the
second half of the game with my son last
night in to see him who probably really
doesn't can't appreciate the full box
body of work you know just go crazy
watching Kobe finish that game just says
you know says a lot about the the way he
performs and the way he close to gain as
a guy that played 13 years how
impressive in particular Shareef was
that fourth quarter because I thought
you know I'm not an MBA guy but I
thought Utah was playing pretty good d I
thought a lot of those were contested
shots and they needed every one of them
to win the game um I mean extremely
impressive you know extremely you know I
didn't you see the the mental toughness
and physical toughness and the passion
that allows him to have the kind of
career that he did
there was a you know real gut-check you
could see he was laboring he's tired but
he's figured out a way to you know as he
did a lot to learn his career mighty
done was just you know fitting then he
was able to you know kind of finish and
finish finish the game that way and have
that sort of game and you know you said
all of the points that he scored they
were meaningful points talking with
Shareef abdur-rahim use the third
overall pick back in that 1996 draft
when the Hornets drafted Kobe Bryant and
then traded him to the Lakers not the
finest move in Hornets franchise history
to say the least
you know Shareef every time I hear an
NBA guy they talk about how impressive
it is that certain guys get as many
shots as they do because it's tough to
get shots off to the layperson who looks
at Kobe having 50 shots and just thinks
he was gunning why is it impressive to
you how many shots certain guys can get
off at times well my opinion assists
like he wasn't done you know we're glad
that down I think he said that at one
time it was okay for him to good but I
think I think the thing that that you
have to keep your perspective one you
know not a lot of guys that like you're
taking can keep the number of shots off
anything you know I couldn't even you
know create space and get up over guards
and you know have the creativity to
change stuff like that but it but also
we sometimes it's in competition and
competing like your team they needed
them to take them shots you know least
the ones in the second half they need
them to take all of those shots and you
know I guess in a you know a pure
basketball sense and you want to apply
to be involved you know you do you don't
want other guys to touch it a little bit
more but I looking at their roster like
I don't know who else could you know
take those sort of shots could keep
their own shots to wait any chair I mean
he really you know he really is right
there their best
you know player so
you know you have to keep that in
perspective 15 shots is a lot of shots
with the thing that makes it you know
okay I think you know one is his last
game and then to like the shots and many
were all shots that you needed down the
stretch and they won the game how much
did you know about him Shareef back in
96 when you guys were drafted and and
what did you think about a guy going
right to the NBA from high school back
then well in high school of the year
heading him so we know I'm fighting at
each other in there you know different I
shoot shoes to sneaker all-american
carrying stuff so at that time it was a
nice evening so we you know like he was
dead I was going into my senior I still
use furniture his junior year so you
know like I remember him I remember
being I can to seeing him and he was
regardless of the class you were in her
ancient is really really good
he kept up like with the older guys you
know like going from high school to the
NBA was like at that time was really a
new thing I think the year before Kevin
Garnett was in the same high school
class as I was he did it and like I
remember you know being around like we
just thought he was crazy and you know a
couple of guys did it that next year you
know in that dress that I was in I think
it was
Kobe and your name did it but I just
think you know even NBA folks they
didn't think that you know guys were you
know prepared at such a young age to
play in the NBA you know our three guys
like Kevin and Kobe Lea and Jermaine
O'Neal made NBA for me big a little
differently from the way they performed
and even performed at a young age but
you know it was just such a it was such
a new a new kind of phenomenon at the
time there you know you didn't know what
to expect but you know he was you know
like you knew you you know he was really
really child he's really good like
remember being young you're planning
like magics of his after all
here playing in magic it is like
all-star gearing still in LA and
watching him and kidding they've kind of
gotten a thing where they were going
back and forth with each other and you
know at this one you know like Jenny was
the senior he was the guy and in that
exchange you wouldn't have known like it
was um so you know he always had that
competitive spirit you know always
wanted to compete always going to show
so you know the success and you know
that part of it you know you can never
kind of plan out a dream out that a guy
even you know will have the level of
success he's had but you know he was
always kind of driven that way your
challenges enough to do the things that
he he's dead
talking with Shareef abdur-rahim he was
the number three overall pick back in
1996 when Kobe Bryant was drafted by the
Hornets came out of high school
let's talk warriors a little bit Sherif
what's more impressive to you staff
going for over 400 three-pointers or for
them getting 73 wins without a dozen 70
wins and watch the grueling nature of an
NBA season and the Delta NBA season long
B's work nine games you know there's a
heck of a heck of a season but that's
extremely impressive and I think you
know even you know what makes it even
more impressive is the way they had to
do with our stretch they put themselves
in a situation where you know I watched
fourth quarters of the game and Memphis
like they had to when they get ahead and
they plays their Eddie gets tossed a lot
of stuff you know you know I wasn't a
blowout nobody you know was laying down
for them and then in fairness only well
you know you had some teams that were
really playing for something Joe yeah it
was you know the way they did it was
really a person but I think the 403
that's hard to even put a project and I
can't because anyone you know at least
for the time that I've been connected to
the immunity or parachurch the
basketball that feeling anything close
to their soul that that's hard to put
into context and that's best
like 73 wins you know I'm sure he'll say
is the the more impressive statistic
Sherif really appreciate the time and
putting some perspective into a guy
that's a fellow member of the 1996 draft
class thanks so much for coming on the
Dan Patrick show yeah thank you all
right there he is Shareef abdur-rahim
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience